hey texas new york philadelphia take the
jolly ranchers out of your ears and
listen up because the keep it moving
tour is coming your way yeah guys uh
it's a stand-up show when we play ayg
with the audience it's a good time uh
september 30th we're going to be in long
island
and then
what are we doing we're going home for
cheesesteaks
whiz wit baby october cheesesteaks and
vengeance october 27th we're going to be
at helium comedy club in philadelphia
get those tickets they're gonna move
fast i'm telling you yeah do it yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r u garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find that they go to be classy yeah or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host stage foley coming at you
on a beautiful day down here aunt
toddy's basement she's very excited to
have our guest back with us today said
she was in the audience of a tony and
tina's wedding back in the years ago
jersey good looking guy in the cast they
went out and had a drink sparks flew it
could be a misconnection i don't know
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me he is the ceo of are you
garbage he's an international
businessman he did his first hostile
takeover at the age of nine
so do me a favor show them a little
respect and give it up for kevin james
ryan hey gang happy to be here thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
you rate view uh rate review subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are
when you point i talk yeah true to roof
true to [ __ ] roof uh youtube's
cooking and then obviously
uh
patreon.com is the greatest website ever
made uh you can sign up you get bonus
content episodes of hard feelings live
streams the whole [ __ ] nine yards get
involved people and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man he makes us
all look good first bunt of the night
right there give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody
it's from
oh i've seen the film
okay i'm sorry gang we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly special
guest back with us again today he is a
very funny stand-up comedian podcaster
and actor he has a brand new podcast
coming out called macaroni rascals with
our good pal greg stone and he is going
to be filming a brand new hour october
23rd at governors in long island do us a
favor give it up for the one the only mr
mike vecchio yeah
thank you guys for having me back of
course of course buddy thank you for
coming it's great happy to have you it's
great to be here
and i'll tell you what i didn't shower
no before this why not i had the
opportunity cause are you garbage you're
just coming i came in as garbage you
want to come in as garbage and work my
way to a um
civilian have you worked out have you
worked out today no you haven't cause
you to me seem like an up at dawn going
for a run guy
i used to see you running around astoria
yes yeah i used to say i would live in
his hands
he'd be looking like he's trying to make
weight for the for the match this week
that's what i'm saying man i feel like
you're up at five cold shower cold calls
well this is uh i'm not up at five i'm
still a comic
so um but i moved you guys both know i
moved sure yes so i moved into the city
and oh i don't know you're in the city
yeah you're a city becky who's a city
guy i'm a city guy now look at him so if
i talk down to you guys that's what it's
about
bridge and tunnel moving up brunch every
day baby you know you burrow guys i live
on the island too okay oh do you yeah
all the way up town in the nosebleeds
but
all right well i'll give you a little
bit
fully i'm sorry i'm gonna have to
we cannot hang out and get a glass of
wine together
we're not gonna do brunch
so i move into this new neighborhood and
uh it's a choice between uh i have a gym
uh options because i realized i was like
oh maybe i could just work out at home
but during the pandemic i realized oh
that's not a thing yeah that's not
really gonna be possible so
uh planet fitness i don't know who
sponsors you guys so i'm sorry if i'm
just bleep this out planet fitness which
is like you can use every planet fitness
in the country for three dollars a month
sure yeah and then there's um
equinox which is a little bit of cash
very expensive yeah it's like what's
that going like 200 a month what is that
uh
235.
stuff he knows because he's in he's in
it
because he are you there to make the
decision
mike becky own uh invest in yourself a
manhattan living equinox guy somebody
successful tweeted that invest in
yourself sure and so i uh
decided to pull the trigger on it oh my
god holy [ __ ] i thought i knew you
thought i smelled a little self-tanner
on you
bronzer on
it's probably from the steam room yeah
have you been in the eucalyptus room for
a little while have an espresso in the
eucalyptus room wow i have an espresso
in the steam room they have an espresso
stand in the steam room actually i don't
think any of our guests have ever
belonged to equinox of course they
didn't they're trash people they're
garbage and i'm talking to you
you're a garbage person what does that
come with your own peloton that you just
take home with you throw out every night
pelotons kill children but
but i think it's worth it we i did a
whole thing on my podcast where um you
know the peloton gets a bad rap because
it goes after your you know tries to
kill your family but
it it strengthens you like you
if if your machine tries to kill you and
then you go out in the world what could
hurt you wait is it killing people i
don't know the story it is killing
people look at the news once in a while
kevin jesus you gotta tune in i mean how
far up town do you live
where you don't all the way all the way
up down
um as high as it goes i went i pulled
the trigger on it and uh now i've been
now
it's this weird thing where it's like i
have to go to the gym i have to go you
have to i go every day to either even if
i'm not like today i'm not gonna really
work out i'll stretch steam and shower
because i have to use the facility wow
and i signed up for a class yesterday
it's about 10 bucks a day or something
or it's like eight bucks a day it comes
out too you'd be missing out yes
wow well i i and they have all these
classes the re the real reasons like
okay it probably wouldn't be worth it
unless oh you have access to all the
classes yoga um all kinds of fitness and
they're free they're not all free
they're free you just have to sign up
you have to get a spot in them yeah you
have to get a spot so i got a spot and
uh now i'm just signing up for classes i
don't even know what they are i just
went yesterday and this guy it was like
a metacon i was like a metcon i don't
know what this is but i was like i'm
almost
i'm gonna make it so i went and i signed
up and then it was
crazy hall and i'm in decent right now
great shape i'm fasting and i've lost
weight and all that stuff so i'm in
pretty good shape ninja training how
hard could that be
i'll grab a protein bar and a smoothie
i'll be in a minute guys it's basically
what it was and i was like i was blown
away afterwards and i was like fir i
went right to the instructor i'm like
look it's my first time he's like wait
this that over there and we did it was
an aerobic weight workout and i am a
mess today really i walked over here to
kind of stretch out
from my place that's
yeah i like the [ __ ] going in taking
the schvitz doing the tanner and
bouncing out of there i get that i heard
the facilities are really nice showers
the whole nine yards it's really nice
and then there's a lobby also where
um
and not a lobby a lounge where
it's a bottle service you know what i
mean
tonight
[Laughter]
dj sweet greens
it's a lounge where i can write or or
whatever
afterwards also so
i just got to put it here do it the
music is pretty now
listen you're now you're rubbing elbows
with the manhattan elite night you're an
equinox well i'll tell you who goes
there i don't know who goes there kind
of surprised me it's um did you ever see
that duke lacrosse documentary 34 30.
yeah yeah yeah yeah about that one about
the dude like they were kind of faceless
to me i know that they got wrongly they
got railroaded yeah railroaded but i
watched the 30 for 30. i'm looking at
the guys on the team and they're like
elite level athletes sure and elite
level in intellect you know what i mean
like i never
i i just you know i never got into that
school
i wasn't that elite of an athlete or
elite of an intellect so i wouldn't got
in there but that's who is at this place
a lot of confidence over here i'm just
happy now i'm letting you know i'm being
honest about who i am thanks for
clearing that up buddy we thought we
really thought you were blue devils
material i thought i pegged you for an
astronaut to be honest with you
this is going to shock you guys but i'm
mostly blue-collar
i mean
so i think you got the tony and tina
scholarship tony and tina's scholarships
so that's who is there duke duke like
duke harvey like those types
guys who are like finance guys and stuff
it's like it's the elite it's it's the
it's it's like the social it's the gym
social club for people in manhattan
right and now also too i think with
those like fancy things that they have
we were talking about this with country
clubs the other day because my brother
joined a country club and then like we
were all there in the pool hanging out
and like they're all so rich they don't
use the pool
like because they all have their own
pools and stuff oh wow
we're garb
[Laughter]
do you
do you are other people using the lounge
and stuff like that or are you the only
guy in there there's a couple people but
it's not it's not that full okay the
lounge isn't that cool but it gets
mike's got an arm full of [ __ ] cliff
bars has anybody asked you for your id
yet why you've been there so would you
excuse me
um
no no one has asked me for my id yet
there i guess our guys i i guess sorry
you're a member here right
sir hey buddy the hvac is downstairs huh
why is that janitor writing jokes has
anyone thrown you any used towels
that's pretty funny it's pretty funny
thank you um i think what kippy's saying
is like do the do the real real rich not
even
use the eucalyptus this thing will not
work out i'll tell you right away i'll
tell you what the real rich do that i
really
like a lot
no one talks i love that no one says
there's a sign in the locker room that
says feeling chatty on your take your
phone take it outside you're also no
selfies in the mirror like they had
there's a sign that says no selfies in
the yeah it might be only the women's
locker room i don't know but i don't
know but that
that's where i like the fact that
there's no talking but everybody's civil
if you need to like get it right like
whatever even on the gym floor it's like
hey there's not a lot of talking and uh
i went to the planet fitness to try that
out too and it's like there's a guy last
night and there's a guy living on the
leg machine basically so it's like
hey come on hey buddy when you're done i
gotta go to bed one too many one too
many pairs of jeans in there you know
what i mean working out in jeans is a
bad loss it's a bad sign and there's a
lot of that
it looks like you're just training to be
a criminal one you look the other way
but two it's like what are you getting
ready for a video game
and also like on that there was this
you know the smith machine with the wrap
with it
i really didn't want to cut me off at
the knees
well there's a smith machine there's
like one or not like a rotisserie
chicken machine or something
yeah i tried to pretend like i knew but
i didn't it's that thing where it's it's
on a rack it's a machine but it's you
can bench on it you can squat on it yeah
yeah oh yeah it's like a guide kind of
yeah it's a guy yeah yeah so uh a guide
is a good
uh way to describe it so there's only
like one or two of them in the gym and
then the last time i was at when i went
to planet fitness at one time um guy
living on the leg machine and then there
there was a guy just
he i don't know if he was doing a
podcast but he had like a full
conversation with another guy for like
an hour on that machine it's like no one
else could get there sure sure holy [ __ ]
oh that's awesome i'll pull the trigger
on it and uh i'm starting to feel you
know does it make you feel good yeah i
do affirmations and stuff i do
affirmations to feel like wealth driven
um affirmations and i don't care if your
fans think it's corny no buddy being at
that gym makes me feel you gotta feel
good healthy yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's awesome i love that this is
actually this is a perfect segue into
the questions um because this is uh so
guys as you know uh we when you join
we'll answer when you join patreon we'll
answer your garbage question on the air
this is a perfect set i had it already
pinned to be the first question to ask
you and this is fantastic this is from
ted do you shower in the gym after your
workout or do you shower at home equinox
i don't shower at home anymore
really i really don't i should shower
better at equinox i always got to be the
showers are not the showers are really
nice yeah and i what i do is i take a
hot steam and i push myself to stay in
there to really sweat it out and then uh
take a cold cold shower
afterwards and then it makes you feel
invigorated you feel alive you do yeah
yeah yeah yeah
some people do drugs or something to
like get that
is the i go the opposite way i start
depriving myself of oxygen
and uh
really that does work it does the same
thing as drugs i used to go to the right
to drugs anymore you're watching turkish
baths a lot down in the east village
that was the same thing you're in the
fit you're in the sauna and then you hop
in that cold pool right you feel [ __ ]
alive everything starts cooking synapses
are firing synapses
that's rich guy thinking right there
i'll tell you that
but i realized that when i was doing
when i did hot yo i did hot yoga in
queens for years and you come out and
it's like oh my god and then after you
take a shower and then walk out i was
like i feel high yeah it's euphoric it's
still high yeah but you're really high
on regular on regular oxygen once you've
been deprived of that in a hot room for
an hour and a half
it's got [ __ ] hard noses
you ever hold your breath for really
long
i do a breathing practice first thing
that's right what do you do four seven
eight what are you doing i do um with
the wim hof
five rounds of tumor breathing
stairs himself he's dropping
i know what he's talking about he stares
at himself in the mirror for 25 that's
right whoever blinks first loses
make a move make a move
i love it
he thinks for his gun real quick
all right this one's just funny this is
from gene have you been electrocuted as
an adult
electrocuted
because if you are you're probably
poking your nose around somewhere it
shouldn't be electrocuted as an adult
or have you been electric even as a kid
no i'd have to say no yeah i would have
to say no but an interesting story about
my father my father was on a ladder
my dad is dead but i feel like i should
communicate you know through this for
him
he was painting on a roof and uh
he got close to some wires or something
and the electricity went through the
paint the paint is a conductor
really uh electrocuted him he fell off
the ladder and cracked his head jesus it
was huge it was when i was small i
remember it though i remember he has a
big scar he had a big scar on his head
damn you know but i stuck a paper clip
in a nightlight once when i was like
really yeah and i got shocked in my
adult in my adult you know i never knew
that when you put the bulb into the
light that there's a little coil there's
a little flat thing in there that that's
what got me that's what got me and that
was that [ __ ] was on and i stuck my
finger in there and the thing made the
connection god damn it was like i got
bit by a blue crab dude i yelled i
yelled something bit me my mom my mom
came into the living room like what the
[ __ ] oh your mom was there i was like
11. i started crying like something bit
me she's like what she thought there was
a bear in the house
and you apparently thought lamps were
alive
it literally it felt like a mousetrap
you put your fam when you're not
expecting that i was looking for the
switches are really curious kids the
sticker um
you guys didn't listen
so my parents were like don't stick your
finger in and they you never did that
you never used to be like but there used
to be no i never did that there used to
be uh
i was uh
obedient as a kid
where's mike he's upstairs doing his
push-ups and going to bed it was at 6 30
it was very obedient because it with
italians it's um i mean respect got
thrown up in my face a lot like sure you
have respect you have respect for your
that's why my friends who are jews it
really makes me laugh because they just
they're asking questions constantly
they're constantly and that's just
that's like their culture sure our
culture is you shut up and do it keep
your head down yeah irish catholics very
the same well yeah do you trust your
parents do you trust your teeth do you
trust your co just do what you're told
then it's all based on that yeah yeah
yeah keep your head down and work yeah
that reminds me the last time we saw
each other was that was was at a wedding
right and dude
is this such a the t man you were like
you were like somebody's step dad you
didn't say a word really hello how you
doing you sat down you sat there and
meticulously ate your meal eyes forward
chilling out then at one point i saw him
on the dance floor he was sitting in a
chair
like dude he really does mind his piece
of cues i love it i mind my own business
uh but no it's you you sit i'm not he's
never been electrocuted
that really helps with the electrocution
um i stopped drinking i stopped i
started fasting you know during the
pandemic because i was uh overweight and
whatever so i started doing all that but
that wedding was the first time like
everybody's gonna be drinking every day
just
sit in it enjoy it you know you didn't
you didn't booze that was the first
taste yeah it was the first big test but
katie like had a couple drinks and like
she's having a good time so i was like
it was but i had a really i had a blast
it was like sitting next to him it was
like sitting next to an uncle at a
wedding
yeah i mean you could tell he cared
about you he he gave me the has
everything going going good like
everything's going good he's like good
good good good
hard
i put my hand on your head let me know
if you need any money
um
can i tell you a story about that though
did you guys go hiking on that because
it was an upstate i saw you right after
the hike remember we bumped we bumped
into each other
he was
no i didn't go hiking i just bumped into
you i went again what are you crazy i
was at the pool i was smoking cigs in
the pool that's pretty great i had uber
eats on the way that's pretty great
that's trash
you guys are living up to your name even
in your spare time also before you
finish we were out on the back deck i
don't know if you remember you started
[ __ ] crushing me i was like like he
came out we were all talking and i'm
like all right i'm gonna grab a drink or
whatever and like i like stood up and he
goes oh what in front of everybody's
like is this not a garbage enough for
you kevin
everybody started laughing at me he's
just he's got a thousand tags so he's
just [ __ ] going i just sat back down
i'm like all right i'm like i'm taking
this one like a nail gun on your own on
your own porch you've taken the podcast
world by storm
and i'm not going to let you get away
with it at a wedding
camp let's talk about bespoke post and
that box of awesome they got i love them
fellas guys and gals over there quick
story for you my eyes are a little a
little hazy because i was out went on a
little nature walk with the lady did you
brought my bespoke post hammock with us
had a little spot right there by the
river it was absolutely fantastic
fall coming in yeah you got to get your
hands on a box awesome travel outdoor
grooming whatever you want send you a
nice little box and be ready for the
fall guys it's so easy to get started
just take the quiz at box of awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for you they
release new boxes every month across
tons of different categories cool stuff
they hooked me up i mean i got a knife i
got you know we got like the outdoor box
so i got a knife i got a duffel bag
cause i like we travel a bunch uh i love
opening boxes with my the cool knife
they get even in my apartment i feel
like look real cool apple picked i feel
i feel woodsy you know what i mean
so it's free to sign up and you can skip
a month or cancel at any time each box
only costs 45 bucks but here's the thing
baby they have over 70 worth of gear
inside
it's cool guy [ __ ] is what it is it's
cool guys stuff you you're like i don't
know where'd you get that thing bespoke
post the the box of awesome helps you
out you know what i feel like a man uh
you get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code garbage at checkout
that's
g-a-r-b-a-g-e at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box do it
gang this podcast is brought to you by
the good people at better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help can help
all right they will assess your needs
and they'll match you with a licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with them in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not a
helpline it's professional counseling
done securely online
yeah guys uh you can log into your
account anytime send a message it's easy
peasy better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy uh and free to
change counselors if need be better help
you better help want you to start living
a happier life today
visit betterhealth.com garbage that's
betterhelp h-e-l-p and join over one
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional a special offer
for ru garbage listeners will get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage
uh that's 10 off your first month
betterhelphelp.com
garbage folks let me tell you about the
good people over there at lathe weeks
late weights yup i'm sure you guys are
just like us you like a little wine
these days you want to know what you're
talking about you want to know where
it's coming from you want a little bit
of variety you gotta get in touch with
lathe weights yeah uh lathe weights uh
wine subscription is an easy way to
bring exciting new wines right to your
doorstep unbox a world of wine with easy
access to different and unexpected wine
makers from all over the globe um sounds
so classy wine subscription it does how
nice is that yeah that's nice oh well we
have a subscription they send it to us
here's the thing lightweights does all
the heavy lifting for you they taste
over 40 000 wines a year but only 600
make the cut this is you so you're
getting the best of the best the cream
of the crop they're not just setting out
you know
some pinot noir that they're brewing in
a bathtub somewhere they do it nice man
they do it nice and this way you know
the the coolest thing uh is each box
whatever wine they send it includes
tasty notes food pairings the
inspiration like serving inspiration
stuff like that that i'm trying to learn
as i get older i feel like a bozo and i
don't know that story sure you know and
like they they sent us each one and now
like i know i'm learning a little bit
about it oh instead of just being like
this that i just think from there from
the moment it makes me feel like less of
a bozo 100 and from the moment that that
box gets there you're gonna have
knowledge about eight different wines
off the jump i feel like a rich guy uh
run your mouth at parties for the next
three weeks yeah uh subscriptions are
flexible there's no commitment to
continue to cancel online at any time
right now uh listeners you can get six
amazing bottles of wine plus two bonus
bottles two stemless wine glasses for
49.99 plus tax with free delivery of
course they're doing free delivery
because late weights knows what they're
doing just text garbage to 64 000 to get
this special offer text garbage
g-a-r-b-a-g-e
to sixty-four thousand that's garbage to
sixty four thousand terms apply
available at lathe weight dot com slash
terms dewey
now back to the show but the hiking um i
have to tell you this story this is
really funny uh i'm dating a very funny
comic katie hannigan yes 100
she goes i really want to go hiking it's
for the endorphins all that stuff and i
go that's cool and we're staying in a
very i've never tried holding your
breath for a half hour
save some time i'll get the ice baths
ready
she refuses to do the breathing
i've tried met many times anytime anyway
we're we're we're staying in this nice
we're staying by a lake this nice
outdoors beautiful
property well she goes i want to go
hiking i go cool let me just finish this
coffee and eat something and then let's
go hiking because i had a nice beautiful
breakfast there and i had some coffee so
i'm like oh cool let's go and she goes
no no we can't i thought hiking was just
walking outside while being aware of
nature i thought that's what hiking was
no that was mine yeah a working
knowledge of hiking she goes now we have
to drive to where we hike
so i go okay
so we drive
not that far and we get there and then
we'll end up
we're on a mountain
and i go what are we doing she goes yeah
this is hiking i go no we're climbing a
mountain yeah yeah she doesn't know
i go
no this is climbing a mountain she goes
well we're hiking up a mountain i'm like
don't improv yes yeah yeah it's called
spade space yeah yeah we're climbing up
a mountain so we got into an argument on
the mountain and then i was like well
i'm gonna i'll just google it you know
and there's no wi-fi yeah
i complained
i'm like this mountain has no wi-fi i'm
gonna give this mountain a very low
rating yeah i saw him afterwards in the
snack bar he was pounding water yeah i'd
only fill up like those like six ounce
cups yeah so he's slamming those i guess
he's like did you go hiking i'm like
[ __ ] no hiking i got suckered into that
before too in hawaii he's like oh we're
gonna go to the waterfall oh nice you
shouldn't no there's not gonna be a
waterfall in the neighborhood
i mean that's an excursion i wasn't
expecting it in the mall or anything
like that but i didn't think it was
going to be like i'm hanging on the
rocks and doing that yeah hike sir
take a hike with a hike i'll tell you
that right now isn't there a hike on
flat land though it's like where you're
walking it's a nice wall
i think implies a trail and
elevation changes oh okay i don't think
it's not necessarily what's a hike what
do you got the activity of going for
long walks especially in the country or
woods okay that we were in the country
or the woods
100 i don't know let's throw the
mountain [ __ ] in there yeah the
mountain the elevation is really what
got me because then i was furious with
her and i stormed off
and it's hard to storm off when you're
going vertically
your screams are echoing around the
woods i hate you and then do you guys
remember that they were like oh there's
bears around but if you just yell at
them if you just yell at them it's fine
yeah one rolled through the cocktail
yeah like really like yeah
20 yards from where we were all like
smoking cigs like out by that where
everybody's like smoking cigars and
stuff it just you saw like the [ __ ]
it was kind of like jurassic park when
you would see just like the bushes move
and stuff like that and then like the
kitchen staff came out like get out of
here get out of here and then we're like
everybody's fine they just laughed at
that wow i mean i went inside for sure
it's probably just some dishwasher they
do that i think it's a tourist of thrill
let's go give these city slickers uh to
get their money's worth
did you guys get hammered
uh the first night i mean yeah the first
night we got pretty banged up stayed out
late the second night i was sitting in
the
the second hour we were sitting we were
the same night we were sitting outside
that bar right in like that whatever the
road house yeah i was sitting next to
him same spot same everything as the
night before and he did the same joke to
this woman she walked out with her kid
it's a good joke she walked out with her
baby he goes how do you two know each
other that's really god i love that dude
oh i love that
that's that's one that really just gets
you it's great i mean i love that song
what the [ __ ] are you doing you're
saying that livered's gonna be using it
now oh my god the son of a [ __ ] so he
does it the first friday night kills
like people jumping off the balcony i
love that
kills the second night the same woman
and baby walks out he's just drunk and
all [ __ ] up how do you two know each
other i was like i see we're in reruns
if it ain't broke don't fix it that's
great i literally can't believe it
what are you doing i think it was a
different kid all right i mean there was
only two kids there you know what i love
to do if i see a woman who's pregnant i
walk up and go um
who got you in trouble
it's a very fifties thing to say to
somebody who got you did you dirty
did your father know about this
the [ __ ]
so i had a great time
[Laughter]
the wedding was a lot of fun it was a
good time we've talked
you made me think we talked about it
we've been talking about it for like two
months the wedding because we talked
about it before we had casey b on the
whole thing yeah yeah yeah it was really
fun ah man that's great i went to uh
eating now is the new drinking for me
yeah eating i really get it get it are
you going out for like nice things or do
you cooking what are you doing no i'm
fasting so it's like i'll have limited
meals so when i do get to eat it's like
drinking it's like ah it's like you're
it's like yeah it's like taking your
edge off
what's it called your vice yeah per se
yeah um all right this one's from chris
scott anyone in your family a flat
earther
no uh i don't think my family knows what
that is
family doesn't know all the conspiracy
they're like what didn't we solve this a
long time ago
that's a thing
that's how not into technology my family
is that's good yeah they don't know all
the conspiracies and all that stuff oh
man that's great uh all right this one's
from alex tanello how yellow is your
pillow
you got some stains on there mikey no
i'll tell you the truth um that's single
guy [ __ ] dude
well i don't understand the reference
how yellow is diabetes no you sweat and
then it leaves like a sweat ring okay
yeah um
you take the pillow case off and then it
has like crazy stains on the actual
pillow now i would have to assume yours
growing up was probably like that
uh yeah i had a no he was very obedient
i had a beat up uh pillow growing up
because we didn't buy anything new i
felt like buying new things is like a
that's a new relatively a new thing to
me because we didn't we didn't buy i got
to agree it's the same thing of like
just going and buying stuff i'm like oh
i can just go buy this
they have then my family was like well
let's see
do we know what guy is aunt patty yeah
i'm like let's just just go get the bike
or whatever mikey did you have an actual
comforter when you were a kid or was it
just an opened up sleeping blanket or a
sleeping bag no i had a um
i had a very just uh
standing upside down actually standard
military just a navy seal bed
[Laughter]
no standard issue foot locker
no i shared a room with my brother until
like uh
probably two weeks ago no older brother
younger older older so i shared a room
with my brother and we had bunk beds at
first
and uh but i gotta say uh when i was um
single
i've had girlfriends you know in and out
but
i yeah they changed the whole game but
yeah i would just i don't i'm not a big
change the sheets guy right
you know once in a while maybe what's up
because i'm i'm waking up i'm sure i'm
sure i'm winning though what
what date or like how long how big of a
i didn't hear what you said i said i'm
sure katie is though okay that's that's
what i was gonna yeah
she's like she'll change it every week
yeah i go dude like come on we can't
she's like no she so she just does it
she just does it now because i'll like
complain about it so uh yeah that's the
change like me before i would i mean it
would go push it months
i mean a long time
a month i mean one time when i was
living uptown in inwood like i think it
was a year yeah yeah i think it has like
a deep winter smell oh my god it was uh
i didn't smell or anything it just
because that would have caught my
attention to do it but i just it's not
something i thought about but she does
it like every week now
sometimes it's nice when they're all
worn in like that yeah yeah cold winters
night you feel like scrooge tucked in
there all right the germs really are
comforting after a while changing them
changing the bed sheets now even like
when like if my wife's like hey can you
help me i feel it takes me back to when
i was like five right my mom was like
make the bed i feel like a child yeah is
that when you weren't electrocuting
yourself
what i was saying i'm not electrocuting
myself i helped change the sheets
what i was saying is it's nice that they
do that because it elevates you like you
know it elevates your game like you
can't have a yellow pill now when you
were a single guy in your own place yeah
those pillows are being changed out on a
monthly ride mine's yellowish for
different kinds of fabric softener or an
air freshener right right it's actually
pretty nice that is pretty nice yeah but
i did have a yellow pillow now that i
think about it because i never i never
bought a new pillow no never bought a
new pillow if i wasn't changing the
sheets i certainly never bought a new
pillow
yeah yeah you're not just getting a new
pillow and keeping it moving yeah so i'm
a little bit garbage there how many
pillows do you do i think i don't know
if we asked this oh i like uh
it i like two because i like to hold one
yeah there we go yeah that's garbage
is that garbage or is that just being
vulnerable
yes being vulnerable being vulnerable is
garbage
we're stoic around here mike
i do the same thing i hold that
on to that thing like a [ __ ] search
and rescue guy and then you get a your
girl going why don't you hold me like
that it's like it doesn't functionally
yeah it doesn't geometrically it's nice
and cool and fluffy right doesn't have a
pulse
doesn't
doesn't judge me
the pillow doesn't care if i snore honey
he didn't break my balls for five hours
today
do you snore are you a snorer no no oh
yeah okay
i sleep quietly
with a blade and my eyes open ready for
anything just a fedora pulled down over
his eyes in a chair
so my case propped up with a cigar
burning in the ashtray
well if i'm sleeping who's on watch
[Laughter]
i i don't think our relationship would
work if i did snore because katie has to
sleep with complete
silence my wife said my wife's kind of
just a complete silence so i have to put
ear plugs in cause i gotta sleep to
something you know lulling me to sleep
so your plugs are like air pods you
sleep with music yeah yeah yeah wow i
sleep with like you got headphones on in
bed
that's yeah crazy and uh are they wired
or no no no do they stay in yeah you
probably don't toss and turn a lot
you're probably an old disc you're
probably a straight up and down kind of
guy straight up and down yeah
i'll go to a side once in a while but
mostly they'll stay in yeah but i got to
say something about like
sleeping quiet like um you know i i'm
i like to sleep quiet but
sometimes things wake you up
they're so hilarious like things like um
we were in queens and uh we were
sleeping and it's like saturday morning
it was like 9 00 a.m
this chainsaw
is so like right outside there but
sometimes it's comically it's comically
loud it feels like it feels like you're
in the room you're like what the [ __ ] it
feels like the guy was in the room it
was really something so i'm like kind of
waking up going oh this is you know i'm
disturbed by it but this this is so loud
it's funny
she did not find the same amusement park
in it and it's like what do you do do
you go out and confront a guy with a
chainsaw no not at all yeah yeah yeah
you're kind of screwed at that point
right
uh
do uh do you set an alarm in the morning
you just wake up when you wake up i wake
up when i wake up i love that yeah it's
pretty good but i i have to like uh
pee
in the morning so uh i usually that
usually wakes me up about five hours in
yeah and then
if i have nothing i'll go back to sleep
if i do have something that i'll
probably just stay up yeah yeah dude i
hate that so much because i'm starting
to have that too that's the first thing
i got to do and i know that i lay there
for at least an hour to
fighting it off where i'm not like
relaxed sleeping you gotta but i'm like
worried about that because i wake up in
like a bad mood like oh
and you got a [ __ ] sleepy eye to the
toilet yeah i get it i used to push it
but now i just go get it done with now
get back in bed and i stole my wife's
eye mask and it's like weighted and it's
got lavender in it dude that puts me off
for i don't know i don't know if i'm
allergic to it or if i'm like having if
i'm slipping into a coma i go out for
another like three four hours with that
thing on that's awesome it's cool and
you go right back to sleep um dude you
put this it's like pressure it's like
heavy it's like beaded kind of
and it's just [ __ ] you're out dude
wow ow how did people ever sleep in
caves
i don't know
without all of ours we have all these uh
different ways no ac i'm out
actually the room has to be i would have
jumped off the first locomotive bridge
i'm still pumping my ac now oh yeah i
got it it's on 62 right on right 62.
yeah wow yeah to get the bed yeah i keep
it i set it down seven seven oh man this
guy's old school
what are you a homeowner
who's touching the thermostat
katie don't even look at that okay
it's brisk in there though
but sleep is i mean i mean it's really
important
very very important it is
i don't want to bore your um your fans
here because they probably don't get any
sleep
oh man that's so funny uh all right um
let's see this is from dan d uh
first time question ever take a day off
from school or for a religious holiday
that you didn't practice
a religious holiday and you lied and
said hey um you know
i'm jewish i'm taking off for russia oh
no but i we did i don't know if vecchio
could pass
[Laughter]
um
there's a what's this what's the wooden
the
thing
they put on the door
there's a mezuzah because the person who
owns
the building now the person who burns
the apartment is jewish yeah so they
kept and we just kept it on yeah
90 of apartments in new york have a
mezuzah on the door yeah because in case
the angel of death this is what it is i
don't know what it is it's like
the lamb's blood i don't know exactly
what it does but i know you leave it
there
it gives it it gives you a nice cozy
vibe i'm not a religious guy but i'm not
taking something all right it's there
it's there you leave it up or the if you
take it down the rank goes up
i worked at a greek place one time and
they had it they had the evil eye
hanging down by the window and i didn't
know what that was and i'm over there
like cleaning it and touching it and
moving and i'm like what does this do
he's like keeps the evil spirits around
i'll be in the [ __ ] kitchen
but that's what the italian horn does is
that what it is
you have one no are you a you're i'm not
a jewelry not a jewelry guy
you were given one at some point in your
life though yeah i was given a bunch
yeah i just it never
i would always like wrestle with my bro
like
be wrestling with cousins or brother
whatever and it always get yanked get
yanked there and broken and it just
never
or i could never get into the routine of
putting it on every morning yeah that's
what i forget yeah yeah it's like and
then i'm like oh this is a choice that i
yeah it's weird oh but uh the skip i did
how about um my junior year we had a
senior skip day and no one was going to
school not juniors or seniors sure but
it was a senior skip day and uh i told
my mother i'm like i'm taking off and i
made the mistake cause i thought we you
know we're all on the same page now
basically an adult
and she goes now you're going to school
and i go yeah but no one's going to be
there and she goes it doesn't matter
it's school day you're going my mom's a
teacher yeah so she goes you're going
you think she would know the idea it's
like uh
i'm like right no one is a little
rewarding i mean yeah not my senior year
my senior year i i learned yes there's
also junior this is junior year so but
i'm like no one is gonna like no one's
gonna be there no one not juniors or
seniors many sophomores and freshmen
will be there but not juniors or seniors
what am i a nerd yeah what am i here she
goes you're going so i went and no one
was there you were like the only guy
well i mean the class was like you know
you go to class and they were like you
could just do a puzzle or something yeah
it was a complete
waste but i did go because i didn't want
to be you know i didn't
didn't want to disappoint your mother
you're an obedient guy
do a puzzle and then the next year we
had senior skip day and i just we just
went we got um
beer and went to a a lake and just got
obliterated
it was a great time it was really fun i
remember having such a good time yeah
yeah better than the puzzles huh it's
better than the puzzles
i think it's better than listening
public school kids
we we get we get a pretty nice dose of
that well you don't have to really do
that like you don't have to really fake
they give you off for like every for
everybody's different holidays i also
think it depends on where you're at
like we grew up in philadelphia there's
a large jewish community saying with new
york and boston but i think if you're in
the middle of minnesota i don't think
you're getting off your kids the kids in
omaha aren't riding the ramadan coaching
we're in the age of the internet so
everybody is connected to everybody's
conscious of everything i feel like well
i used to work my uh my last day job was
at one of my last day jobs was at a law
firm and
they would say because it was also this
was my first time of like hey
back in the day i would work places and
i was like hey if you're jewish you can
take off for this if you know if you're
you know if you're christmas you can
take off for that type thing but you
were expected to be there otherwise if
you didn't observe and they kind of knew
everybo but this was like the first it
was like a new york you know it was a
big law firm and you weren't allowed to
ask
like if you were just like hey i'm
observing
they would go okay like they weren't
allowed to push that's like
that's like covanello you want to get
out of something all you got to do is
call and say hey i got i got a little
fever i don't think it's covered but i
got a little fever yeah that's it you'll
never hear about it again wow
you got that get out of jail free card
for anything moving forward don't you
think there's some abuse with the
businesses now they're like our new
covet hours 11 to 11. i tried
yeah dude i called the post office
because they like left a package or
whatever and it was like dude
due to you know the covet protocols were
you know we're behind like do you suck
before this this is a [ __ ] cop
you were tanking it before
uh
yeah
so yeah that not religious holidays but
a senior skip
senior year nice in public school you
get into october to jewish holidays
you're only in there like two three days
that was my favorite then you got
halloween yeah right start knocking it
out like all right here we go
couple days in november do thanksgiving
you play football right yes yeah i play
football too so it's like you're
you start two weeks before you know
training camp starts like two weeks
before school so you're already kind of
in
double days and all that stuff i like
that i like that in college too that
felt good being there a couple weeks
before getting your getting grounded
troughing off the certain cafeteria
people but did you did you ever do the
thing where it's like you you know i did
it with football and wrestling even more
so but you're just uh because
once a fall sport one's a winter sport
so they go back to back and you're going
one right into the other yeah so it's
like um
you're tired yeah and you just want to
go home after school like everybody else
and there would be a thing where
in our school you'd walk out and people
would walk to their cars and then you'd
walk to the locker room you'd split off
and you would see the people walk into
their cars and i would be like
i just want to go home going off i don't
feel like going to practice smoke weed
hang out with girls do fun stuff
walk into the car see you later yeah
just go and and but you i always you
always had to go the other way i always
had to go to practice yeah that's why i
love this spring to this day i love the
spring i'm not a big no responsibilities
christmas cause we used to have
christmas tournaments and you just have
to cut weight so i really enjoy
christmas i still love christmas and i
was never the christmas guy i mean i i
get what it is and i get there
everything but
everybody works
merry christmas
merry christmas
you all just exchange money envelopes
then go to dinner
but uh the spring is like when i could
like oh i'm gonna go home i'm gonna hang
out with friends sure i'm gonna like ah
it's great nice relaxing here's a
question from mike thank you that
we've been talking about it it's been
talked about a lot you want to wrestle
here on this program let's get out
who do you think you can take me
let's do it what is your favorite flavor
of the beverage known
as gatorade this is a big one they're
very difficult i cannot foresee him
siding with you idiots of course not i
don't think he's even gonna he does i'm
leaving okay can i say something first
that i don't drink gatorade i know it i
don't drink it because it's too much uh
sugar and stuff sodium
yeah but if you before that that's a
rule
as a reason um
the lemon i got that yes and back
because yeah
from before
i don't drink gatorade i don't drink
gatorade because i got a juicer and i
was like but you did when you were a kid
you remember gatorade gum i mean come on
you remember when it was in the glass
bottles yeah the glasses blow your fa
unbelievable yeah youngster unbelievable
marketing for gatorade
[Laughter]
they drowned me out but in the comments
i like that one
i won't show the fans the gatorade man
comes green
comes house to house lemon lime lemon
yeah yeah it's just lemon i think yeah
right
that was gatorade for a while that was
gatorade it was the original that was
gatorade what was next i believe it was
either orange or fruit punch i would i
would say orange is pretty alright yeah
definitely wasn't fierce grape
but i'm glad they finally got to it they
didn't jump to glacier freeze real quick
now we're into axe body spray sense i
think yeah that's the same thing like i
feel like it's a computer generated it's
not like a [ __ ] you know give me a
real deal great something not like wild
cherry [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself i love
them all and you wouldn't recycle the
plastic bottle either you would just
throw it on the street like an adult
littering back in the 90s was wide open
yes yeah i don't agree with it i don't
literally now but back in the day you
know how many times you'd be driving you
see a mcdonald's bag fly out the open
window to the point though that now you
don't really see you think you would
still see that stuff out there if it buy
would take so long to buy or degrade i
haven't seen a lot of cleanup i haven't
seen a big mac styrofoam thing in a long
time well can i say a joke i used to
have where it's like i want to be rich
enough for you um i'm driving by uh a
sign that says littering a 200 fine but
i throw a mcdonald's bag out the window
and i hits a cop cop grabs it and then
um chases me and comes to the window and
goes this is uh you littered this is a
200 fine and i go officer open the bag
and he opens it and it's 300 inside
yeah i should have set it up no no i
like it that way oh yeah
that's funny
um
all right let's see here this is from
josh's is just a silly one ever have a
unibraille
uh no but uh my individual brows i never
had the heavy in the middle even though
i'm italian but uh
the brows do get out of control they get
they get like they start growing outward
and stuff yeah yeah it's just the hair
in general like uh
ear hair i never had an issue with it
before maybe two years ago or it starts
growing like
and like it's trying to get wi-fi it is
like growing out of the top of my i have
to pluck them i'm gonna battle with it i
just do when i go to get my eyebrows
waxed i have them do my ears too knocks
it right out what's eyebrow what's what
does that entail because i'm all i would
have shaved i would have you no it's wax
do a little things
top bottom do the middle because i would
have a unibrow wow been fighting that
fight my whole life yeah i don't get it
i'll get some in there then i have to
clean up every cup but like it never it
never bridges the gap you know what i
mean you just get it it gets messy what
does that mean if it does huh what does
that mean if it does it needs to mean
you need a [ __ ] bic razor [ __ ]
right down the middle you can't be
walking around high school with a
[ __ ] uni baby
yeah that's a bad luck mike what that is
a bad look but you got a good head of
hair though still still a good head of
hair i like the salt and pepper yeah it
looks great on you well i'm can i make a
confession yeah on your podcast i think
i know what you're going to say i don't
think you have you know what this what's
coming go ahead i cut my own hair i came
off the road this weekend and i think
you know
you cut your own hair i cut it and uh
the the uh
um clippers slipped
and uh i cut a hole in the top of my
head
[Laughter]
wait let me see look towards me oh my
god mikey
[Laughter]
and that's an exclusive that you guys
are getting here on this podcast you
gotta do it at this camera you can't
cover it you got it there you go that's
moving it's covered yeah there it is oh
that's punched in on
me but we have to move forward you got
to get you got to keep trucking you know
keep trucking and you'll grow back and
then uh i i could have just shaved my
head i guess that was the other option
i would have never noticed yeah yeah you
can't notice you know straight on right
straight on but everybody taller knows
hopefully they keep it a secret
[Laughter]
tell them you just had something removed
you're waiting
on a biopsy well my my uh my strategy is
all my bad thoughts will go out of it
keep it positive
um all right this one's from patrick
first time question i can't foresee as
if somebody's classy as yourself i can't
foresee this does anyone in your family
breed animals
breed animals
no
no but i i do have family in ohio
which is um it's around a city but
there's there's it's really like a
country area
rural yeah any hamster farmers
nothing like that no
dogs no no nobody like that that's good
no one breeds animals
that's a bad look if it is if you do
it's never it's messy but you have to be
scientific kind of if you do that i
don't think the people are that's the
problem that's the bad yeah they're not
in a lab like they're mixing beakers
they're having you know given birth to
puppies in like a kiddie pool my boy's
mom had a full a a full a full grow
operation at gerbils it was [ __ ]
really yeah
brutal
there was no signs are people still
growing weed in their closets and stuff
is that still a thing maybe not in their
closet but maybe on the patio yeah is it
legal to do that i don't know what the
weed laws are now everybody's saying
it's legal but i'm like uh it's like all
these things where it's like you can't
sell it but they can't do anything if
you get caught with it it's like all
these that kind of thing yeah yeah
there's you know uh there's definitely
lupus i don't think you can grow it like
you can't just grow it yeah you can't
grow it i don't think i mean like i
think you have to have a license to grow
it right you know
i don't think yeah you can't be it's
like a champagne like you're getting
into the dope game
he's a manhattan guy
i mean how long does it go before all of
this just breaks and gambling is legal
everywhere and they're kind of like oh
that's right on to regulation but it's
just like
just make it i guess just make it it's
already breaking no no i did hey let it
all it's not that we don't need the tab
we need the tax dollars anyway you know
for sure in new york uh you can have uh
up to six
plants uh weed plants per household oh
look at that there you go hmm thanks
cheech look at this
plants per household yeah wow and the
regulation has got to be
for to have like to sell it it's got to
be you've got to be like uh
partners with the government basically
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you ever did that um i think i mentioned
this before uh
that yonkers
they used to have comedy show but in
yonkers yeah at the casinos
it was horrible
it was tough yeah it was tough but i did
it like i did payday i did wednesday and
they sent a car yeah it was very it was
very not a bad caesar salad from what i
remember oh hell of a chicken parm yes
so they used to give you like they
always do the typical comedy club thing
where the first week they give you a
steak and then you go back there six
months later and they're like chicken
fingers yeah yeah yeah your chicken
finger chicken fingers is your choice
now we took the steak off chicken
fingers are one less chicken finger
but um i
i did the first one and um we i met the
guy
he was a son he was a lawyer of the
people who owned it he was a part owner
of it and he was like we're 50 50 with
the government
really yeah he's like i mean gambling it
seems like it seems like you're just
winning like you're making money but
it's like you're your partner yeah yeah
yeah damn yeah so i imagine it's a
pretty sweet probably the same same way
yeah you get hemmed up you call the boys
you know what i mean
you're the first one getting yanked out
of the hurricane situation
blackhawks coming to my house
i got two pounds of orange crush in here
let's go
take the junk up
um all right this one's from edwin uh
how many emojis per text message per
text message do you send i mean you ever
send an emoji emoji's is new for me yeah
what are your go to heart
not to me yeah i'm not going to get a
heart to you
guys no i i i love the message
i love the message that you sent i feel
it loud and clear really but uh heart a
thumbs up
and uh whatever the one you're just
going off to touch the thing yeah
you're not going into them um
i will go into them for like a thumbs up
or something you're not a rocket ship or
a ski guy not a flame guy sometimes i'll
just send a um like a a flag that i
don't know what it is
hey
i'll see you on tuesday it's like greek
[Laughter]
it's like what
no i like to send the wrong emojis fire
truck
do you need help please
actually i fire truck question mark
why did you send a fire truck i'm an
arsonist
that's funny i'm big on them you're
pretty big we're we're all pretty big
i'd like to get away from it i like the
crying laughing face is a fun one i
can't even tell what the my vision is
going bad so i was like i can't tell
who's crying it is smirking like oh i
sent you a smirking one it's like i i
don't know yeah it is uh are you gonna
do glasses contacts or
no reading glasses no i'm gonna you're
readers nothing with dignity i'm just
gonna just gonna go blind
got to go blindly
start guessing at a restaurant
do you do chicken
but the next time you guys see me i'll
have a dog
and they're walking through to the table
uh i don't know that's good um all right
uh so we might get we have a couple more
then we'll get out of here mike asks
have you ever had someone you know been
a civil war reenactor
no but i think that's a great
that's really a great um tony and tina's
is kind of like that's right like the
civil war of an italian wedding so yes
let's so that let's break down what tony
and tina's civil war the seventies it's
a fake wedding it's a fantastic i know
you dinners
but keep in mind there's dignity to it
it was our hamilton
it was millville's hamilton
it was south philly's hamilton okay
people were dying to get an invite it
was a fake wedding it was also chicken
parm served with mashed potatoes was it
mashed
potatoes did you cut ours no no
[Laughter]
were you in the original tony and it
wasn't original
there was no i was in there the original
was some junior high somewhere
i was in the south philadelphia version
it's dinner it was dinner theater yeah
go you're part of the wedding act like
you're a part of the wedding you were
the group you were i was tony you were
tony
yeah i was at the v it was at the venice
on 20th and snyder yeah which was rough
saturday nights at the venice saturday
friday saturday and sunday so when i
started stand up i would do stand-up
like you know you couldn't get up in
philly then there was no helium there
was no
um
what's there now um a punchline punch
line the left house was there the laugh
house was there so it was the laugh
house and then that northeast cabaret
cabaret so that's all that was there so
there wasn't that many places to get up
so i would do tony and tina's three
weeks a year and then one weekend i
would like do something do stand up yeah
but i would go to open mics on wednesday
you know i was trying to do as much show
business as you could do in philly at
that time
what would a tony and tina gigg pay
about
thirty
35
dollars thirty five grand
it was thirty five dollars a performance
i would say you weren't doing it for the
money yeah you're in it for the love of
the uh
would they feed you yeah you could eat
dinner and then what are you gonna fake
eat
we would drink afterwards too like the
liquor and stuff that would be a good
time yeah i mean the bartenders were
super cool so they would just beat us
yeah and just get hammered and then i
was dating a girl in south philly at the
time who lived a few blocks away so i
was um living in upper darby and then i
would go down to do the wedding and i
would just crash at her place for the
weekend so and she would go to like
center city and stuff to these high-end
places and i would just go to this
real blue collar
i would go to senacity these ritzy
martini bars and i would just get
annihilated and then just crash with her
and then we'd go and have breakfast and
then i would we'd just do the whole
thing again that was all
that was my whole my weekends for a
couple of years i love it yeah i love
that
um all right let's see this is from pete
uh ever date someone that was in prison
nah no okay
just checking you never know never visit
anybody in prison i did have a
girlfriend who told me that uh she
steals
really yeah
sometimes i steal her stuff yeah
shoplift yeah you're not a shoplifter i
can't pay you no no no i can't do that i
can't man i'm a man i'm a big
risk-reward guy oh
have you ever visited anybody in prison
um visited anybody in prison no but when
i taught i taught uh kids with
behavioral problems and when i taught
high school i had a kid go to prison and
i would write him letters back and forth
and he was like it's not good to be in
here he's like it's really rough to be
in here
you know he did some whatever um
he didn't have that long of a sentence
he had
whatever couple years but i did
write him and i would read his letters
because they were all friends with him
the guys and the rest of the kids in the
class were friends with them so i read
them in the letters whoa that's like
[ __ ] to let them know it's like hey
you know don't end up here this is where
this goes sure this goes to jail you
know it's like it's not a good place to
be i mean you guys think it's cool
whatever doing whatever you want yeah
this is where it goes yeah yeah it's
tough i had a body scene i regret asking
you the question
i feel bad got stand in the liver in
here real quick yeah
is it a joke podcast not anymore
okay you know it's not a joke your life
i had a buddy same thing uh right out of
high school he got sentenced to four
years and but he got in a program where
he would go and speak at high schools
being like hey he got all [ __ ] up one
night there's like a fight happening
he's like hey one night can ruin your
life like i was he was playing football
in college and stuff and was like so he
would go to high schools and like give
speeches i remember talking to him via a
letter i'm like man it's really cool
that you're doing that you know like i'm
so proud of you you're really really
realizing and turning around he's like
nah man we just get mcdonald's when we
do those shows so like i just go and do
it that's hilarious
he's doing lying to kids for a [ __ ]
big match whether you're doing it for
the message or the mcdonald's i'd say
oh bully's got his retirement plan
covered
right hey listen kids
need a number two and a bust of
cleveland let's go yeah um all right
let's do one more and then we'll get out
of here uh knockouts some more uh
another first question this is from and
i can't you know uh ever attended a
backyard wrestling show
not like your wrestling like bad wwe no
i i went to some amateur wrestling when
i was in philly though really it was
great i was gonna see if you've ever
competed in one ah no no no no well they
were big in philly even nationally
really was like that philly was one of
the like the headquarters i loved i went
with my buddy and uh he was he was uh
bouncing and coaching a team there so he
was like a special guest referee
it was just great i love that chaos yeah
i love it actually i was just watching
um
old andy kaufman
um oh that was enough that's right
i love him screaming i'm from hollywood
you're from the south you're dumb i'm
from hollywood i was talking to nate
like nate was telling me about it so i
started i went down a rabbit hole and
just like looked it up and uh it's he's
screaming i'm from hollywood i'm a star
you're nothing i
i mean i really just i love it yeah yeah
it's great that's too good
all right very good all right gang that
is the episode uh mr vecchio like we sat
october 23rd filming a brand new ghost
tower he's the best joke writer in the
world thank you come to long island
please come to governors and uh for the
special and also support uh
uh macaroni rascals my new podcast on
patreon with greg stone and also my
regular podcast on gas digital mike
vecchio investigates gaming or gaining
um steam
so i'd like to have you guys both of
course
absolutely fantastic thank you buddy
give me what do you got for him uh guys
come to a live show uh
we have long island as well we have
philly coming up we're gonna have a new
york city date we're announcing hey
it's gonna be good get some cards and
some koozies we got some merch the whole
nine yards we'll be doing a new merch
drop soon with uh t-shirts gang we love
you we'll see you next week